[Music]
we're finishing Today's Show with
another update in the Alec Murdoch Saga
a federal judge granted disgrace South
Carolina attorney and convicted murderer
Alec Murdoch an extension of time to
fight an insurance fraud lawsuit
involving his late housekeepers family
57-year-old Gloria Satterfield died in
2018 after an alleged trip and fall
accident at the Murdoch's Moselle
property despite satterfield's death
initially being classified as natural a
local coroner claimed her injuries were
inconsistent with the trip and fall
accident since 2021 satterfield's death
has been under criminal investigation by
the South Carolina law enforcement
division or sled fast forward to the
present day and Murdoch is serving life
in prison at South Carolina's McCormick
Correctional Institution for the murders
of his wife Maggie and Son Paul now
while behind bars Murdoch is fighting a
federal lawsuit against an insurance
company accusing him and his former
friend of pocketing over four million
dollars in insurance settlements that
were aimed for satterfield's children
and Murdoch's filing he argues that the
facility has restrictive prison
conditions that quote creates logistical
complications for him in this litigation
his team has until May 1st to respond to
the to the lawsuit to give you a little
bit more contacts to this context to
this let's rewind back to Murdoch's
trial when satterfield's son was
questioned about this settlement money
did he ever tell you about a 505 000
settlement that already had occurred no
did the defendant ever tell you that he
also had a five million dollar umbrella
policy no
did he ever tell you that there had been
a recovery against that no
did he ever tell you that had been a
recovery for 3.8 million dollars against
that no
did he ever pay you one penny of 3.8
million dollars no
so Terry extensions are family Fairly
common in civil cases but do you agree
with the judge's decision to Grant this
particular extension for this reason
well I didn't think it should be granted
first of all you're right they are
generally granted especially if it's
only for the first time but here we do
know that Gloria Satterfield died in
2018 it's now five years later and these
children needed that money they have a
brother who is not able to testify he's
disabled you know they've been waiting
for a long time so I definitely think
that time is of the essence and that
just is denied is not what should happen
here so I hope that this is the one and
only extension the only good news is
that it was a short extension and
perhaps the judge will allow it to go
forward from here well Brian when we
talk about limitations what limitations
is Alec Murdock facing when he's
preparing for a trial in prison well
Jesse it's really about time and
resources and oftentimes in prison you
don't have much of either other and so
the inability to just sit down on a
laptop and and read Discovery for three
four hours and maybe the middle of the
day Alec may not be able to do that
because he's in prison
welcome back everybody a Minnesota
mother of two has been missing since the
end of March and her family is pleading
for people to come forward with
information here's what we know so far
26 year old Madeleine Kingsbury dropped
her two kids off at daycare with their
father Adam Fravel at around 8 A.M on
March 31st then at 8 15 a.m Kingsbury's
van returned back to the home she shared
with frayville in the city of Winona at
10 A.M her van departed her home and
returned back to the Residence at 1 30
PM as for frail he told police that he
left their home at 10 A.M and when he
returned Kingsbury's phone wallet jacket
were all still inside but Kingsbury was
nowhere to be found this week Kingsbury
sister Megan spoke with long crime about
the mother's disappearance and the
evidence currently at Play
she'd never gone off on her own
I've never been without Kim
Ira even for a day for for years
um you know and she she had plans for
the near future and for years into the
future as well you know she uh she was
supposed to come to my house the next
day with her daughter if plans change in
any type of way I know like immediately
from her she had plans and things that
she wanted to do in the future so she
wouldn't have just left we're trying to
piece together
um you know wear her car was in between
the time that it left her home and when
it returned so I think it's between like
ten and one on that day of um March 31st
so
um yeah and it's not clear who was
driving the vehicle
um you know there is as far as I know
some surveillance video of the van at a
gas station in Rushford Minnesota just
kind of driving by but you can't see you
can't see who's driving it so
um so yeah and any footage that they are
able to get that has even a glimpse of
of the van would be extremely helpful
and I know there's people out there that
don't like dealing with law enforcement
there are ways to
um give tips anonymously no one has to
know who you are
um so if that's you and you know
something I would I would take advantage
of that
um you know there's
there's no harm in helping here
essentially so we we just ask that if
anyone knows anything
um that they they please just come
forward with that information
Kingsbury sister also shared details
about Madeline's plan to live separately
from Fravel the two had ended the
relationship and wanted to live close to
each other for co-parenting purposes
since freyville didn't have primary
custody of their two kids according to
court documents social workers and
police visited frayville on April 4th to
take the children and the father was
reportedly non-cooperative in the
process you see at one point freyville
allegedly took the younger of the two
children back into their home and locked
the door despite being told that Winona
County has was legally responsible for
the kids frabel has denied any
involvement in Kingsbury's disappearance
and no suspects have been publicly
identified by authorities the young
mother's disappearance is still
considered involuntary and suspicious
Brian I'll start with you police aren't
giving the public a lot of information
here similar to what we kind of saw in
the Brian coburger case you think police
are being tight-lipped for the same
reason absolutely Jesse I think that
there are enough pieces here similar
it's like you mentioned in the co-burger
case we have a vehicle we have eyes out
there the families already put a fifty
thousand dollar reward for any
information and from what I understand
many tips are coming through I think we
should probably learn from the co-burger
case and maybe take a step back allow
law enforcement to do their job and see
where the information leads and
hopefully it leads to the arrest of an
individual and I know we don't often see
people recovered in situations like this
but I think we should still keep some
hope for that as well yeah no listen we
are all hoping and praying for the safe
return of metal in Kingsbury that would
be the best result here um Terry law
enforcement as we've been talking about
they haven't named a suspect but you
think they've obtained search warrants
for Adam fravel's computer maybe his
phone records well if they haven't Jesse
I think that they should look they need
probable cause to obtain a search
warrant that just means they have to
have a reasonable suspicion that a crime
occurred at that location here that is
supported by the fact this is the
ex-husband he lived there he took the
kids he he has computers there he has
phones there and I think if they go
through that they'll see what the
searches were perhaps maybe he did
Google how to hide a body we don't know
for a fact but maybe he did use his
phone they can look at locations so I
think they're going to do what they do
in most investigations is start from the
inside and go out and the inside is
definitely the person who was closest to
her and that would be her ex so I hope
that they do that I hope that they get
Clues from the public and that they are
able to determine what happened to her
and hopefully she'll come back and
she'll be alive and well and Brian I'll
turn to you real quick on this when we
spoke with Megan she didn't entirely
wasn't clear about how much is being
shared with her by law enforcement if
you're law enforcement how much do you
share details of the investigation with
the family
I think you've got to be respectful to
the family because they are hurting and
they're needing information but you also
don't want for lack of a better phrase
too many chefs in the kitchen if you're
giving out information in terms of your
leads who you're looking into who you're
who you're trying to speak with again
the Brian kohlberg case where so many
people are like look here look here look
there look everywhere you want to kind
of streamline this but still be
courteous and understanding of the
family's needs while continuing your
investigation
one of these things in these cases but
it's just be patient and unfortunately
that's what we have to do be patient the
answers will eventually come one way or
another and we're going to follow it
here on loan crime